那么在接下来的时间里边啊
我们会聊到亲子关系啊
对吧职场的一些思维啊
包括我们自我的一些成长
还有就是
如何面对生活当中的一些误解
那我也希望对吧
咱们的每一番分享
都会像一盏小灯
能够照亮大家生活中
那些正在困扰你的角落
所以先请大家在咱们评论区打两个字
早安啊每个同学动手都打一打
让我们彼此确认一下
对吧今天这3个小时
咱们是一起出发的
我们是一起出发的啊
也愿这段清晨
能够成为你整天的
这么一个能量的来源
好不好啊
欢迎大家对每个同学打一打早安
早安啊
欢迎自在的燕子啊
欢迎冰冰啊
欢迎终不后悔啊
欢迎哦欢迎哇
5啊感谢秋妍的关注啊
感谢大家的关注
早安
对大家可以把灯牌都亮一亮啊
大家把灯牌亮一亮
然后咱们一边点赞一边听好不好啊
各位同学
对不知道怎么亮灯牌的同学
首先点一点咱们这个直播间
松明讲心里
这个直播间的这么一个关注啊
加完关注以后呢
然后点亮这个小黄心啊
小红心都可以啊
然后就可以把咱们的灯牌亮起来了
对加入一下我们的粉丝团
加入一下咱们的粉丝团
欢迎大家啊
那么在生活里边啊
就是很多父母都会有这么一个困惑
这我孩子啊
怎么总爱撒谎那
明明没考好
却说自己得了高分对吧
明明没做完作业
却说作业早就写好了
甚至是摔倒了
都说是同学推他的
一听到孩子撒谎啊你
看
父母的第一反应往往就是这坏习惯
对吧必须得立刻纠正
但如果说
我们只停留在表面的对或者是错
那么
很容易错过孩子内心最真实的呼喊
我们看看孩子为什么会撒谎
那么从心理学的角度来看
撒谎他并不是天生的恶意
而是孩子一种自我保护
和这种自我修复的方式
你比方说
当孩子说哎呀
今天我在学校表现的特别棒对吧
老师还表扬了我
但其实并没有发生过这样的事
那父母可能会觉得很气愤啊
你怎么能胡编乱造呢
可在孩子的内心
他其实并不是要欺骗你
而是想通过编造一个更好的自己
来换一点点你眼里边的光
是不是这样啊
所以这个背后隐藏着一个事实
就是在他真实的日常生活里边
可能呢被否定会比较多
被肯定的少
一次考试没考好
可能得到的是批评
一次举手答错了
可能被嘲笑了
一次勇敢的尝试
可能换来的却是一声冷冷的
这有啥
于是孩子的心里边
他开始出现了一个缺口我需要被看见
我需要被肯定
但我真实的自己达不到
那怎么办
所以撒谎
可能就成了一个暂时的这么一个桥梁
那通过这个桥梁
他可以把不够好的自己给掩盖起来呀
他可以换取一丝的温暖和认可呀
所以当你看到孩子撒谎的时候
我想先我想先请你先停下来
那我想先请你停下来
问自己这么一个问题
他为什么要说这个谎
来我们大家把这一句话打在评论区
他为什么
要说这个谎
啊他为什么要说这个谎
怎么一下就能找到您的直播
那就是有缘分呗
啊
对吧在感召你
所以你找到
他为什么要说这个谎
那接着我来说说答案
大多数的情况下
答案就是他在渴望你的理解
鼓励和肯定
就像有一位心理学家阿德勒说的
他说每一个人
都需要足够的勇气去面对生活
而这个勇气从哪里来呢
那就是从被爱和被肯定中来
那回过头来
那我们父母到底应该怎么做啊
我跟大家说几点
第一点我们叫区分
区分什么呢
区分恶意的谎言和保护性的谎言
我这么说大家能理解吗
首先我们做一个区分啊
孩子如果是为了逃避惩罚撒谎
比如打碎了杯子说不是自己啊
那这个背后其实是害怕父母的责罚
对吧那孩子为了赢得肯定
他会撒谎
比如啊那还有一种呢
就是孩子为了赢啊
他得撒谎啊
比如夸大他的成绩啊
虚构这种被表扬的经历啊
那这个背后其实是渴望父母的认可
所以当你看见背后的情绪
你就会更加的懂得如何的去回应
那么第二点呢
就是多一点正向的关注
你不要等孩子做出大成绩
你才去肯定他
对吧哪怕就是咱们一个小小的努力
我们也要看见哎
比如说哎
你今天主动去做作业了
我注意到了
我看到了
就是这种微小的这么一个认可
那也会在孩子心里边种下真实
也值得被看见的这么一个种子
那么第三点呢
就是允许孩子不完美
我跟大家说很
多谎言的背后
其实是孩子
在和不完美的自己在搏斗啊
如果说父母愿意告诉他没关系
你已经在努力了
我依然爱你
那么这个孩子
就会逐渐的学会接受真实的自己
而不需要通过谎言来粉饰这个东西
那说到这
我想
对正在为孩子撒谎而焦虑的父母说
撒谎它不是一个病根
而是孩子的求救信号
与其急着打压
不如咱们先倾听
当你愿意蹲下来
看见他背后的脆弱和渴望
你就会发现
孩子其实一直在等一个机会
把真实的自己能够交给你
如果你也遇到对吧
如果你也遇到过类似的情况
也可以在评论区告诉我
你家孩子啊
最常说的那个谎言是什么
我们一块来看一看
在这个小小的谎言的背后
其实藏着怎么样的一个心声啊
哼
所以大家记住
撒谎
其实是孩子的这么一个求救信号啊
当你对他否定多
肯定少对吧
他能的
他自己的能力可能只能达到这
但你对他的要求是这
是不是
那中间的这个部分我跟大家说过
可能就是他撒谎的部分了啊
那觉得有收获的同学打一个一字来
觉得有收获的咱们打一个一字来
第一次来的同学
如果觉得有收获的
记得加一加
松明老师这个频道的这么一个订阅啊
订阅一下我们的这个频道
点点关注啊
亮亮灯牌对吧
每天早上这么好的一个时间
咱们都来听一听
每一天我们都会分享不一样的
心理学的一些内容啊
都是和你的生活呀
和你的情感呀
包括和你的职场
我觉得是息息相关的
对吧那么关注我们的频道以后
记得点点赞啊
咱们一边点赞一边听
所以你看
在聊孩子成长的时候
我们常常只是看到了行为的表象
比如撒谎啊
那其实你看
谎言的背后是什么啊
同学们
他藏着一个深深的渴望
就是希望被看见
对吧
当我们愿意从心里的角度去理解他
你会发现
原来谎言并不可怕的
可怕的是
我们错过了孩子想要表达的心声
那么
如果说撒谎的根源是在于被否定过多
那么在亲子关系里边
还有哪些想法
会在不知不觉当中伤害到孩子呢
那么接下来
我就带大家去看一看
父母最应该放下的5个5种错误的思维
很多孩子啊
很多父母在养育孩子的过程里边
常常感到焦虑
对吧孩子不听话
学习不好
总爱顶嘴
爱玩手机
那问题的背后
其实往往不是方法不对
而是我们自己心里的某些思路
成了亲子关系里边
最大的这么一个绊脚石
那么在心理学里边
有这么一句话
他说家庭是孩子的第一个课堂
而父母是孩子最重要的老师
但遗憾的是
很多父母并没有意识到
自己的一些固有的想法
其实正在悄悄的伤害到孩子
那我总结了亲子关系里边
最常见的5种错误的思路
如果说你能够舍弃他们
那我告诉大家
你和孩子的关系会轻松很多
那首先我们来看看第一个思维是什么
第一个思维就是孩子必须听我的
那么很多父母会下
意识的觉得啊
就是我是为你好
对吧你就得照做
但孩子不是父母的附属品
他是一个独立的人
如果说你一直要求孩子必须服从
短期内哎也许能够得到表面上的安静
但我告诉大家
长期只会让孩子失去自我
甚至变得叛逆
那你知道亲子关系他不是控制
而是引导啊
孩子越大
他其实越要学会的就是自主
那么这是第一个思维
第二个思维呢
好孩子就该成绩好
你看太多的父母
把孩子的学习成绩等同于了价值
考得好就是乖孩子
考不好就是不争气
可事实是
学习成绩只是孩子成长的一部分
一个考试
90分的孩子
不一定比80分的孩子更懂得感恩
更懂得合作
更能够适应社会
对吗
所以真正的好孩子是身心健康
他有人格力量
而不仅仅只是分数漂亮
第三个思维我牺牲了一切
孩子就该懂事
很多父母啊
心里边都有这么一种想法对吧
我这么辛苦的赚钱不就是为了你吗
你为什么还不争气
但孩子不会因为父母的牺牲
而自动的懂事啊
相反对吧
如果父母总是为我为你付出了
付出了多少
作为这种压迫感
那孩子的心里边只会越来越沉重
甚至产生反感
所以我们说过
养育不是交换
更不是情感的绑架
孩子需要的是爱和理解
而不是这种债务感
第四个思维问题都在孩子身上
当孩子出现问题的时候
很多父母的第一个反应就是责怪孩子
你不专心
对吧你太懒
你没自制力
但其实孩子的问题
往往是家庭关系的一面镜子啊
一个总是拖延写作业的孩子啊
背后可能是父母的催促和这种焦虑
一个情感暴躁的孩子呢
背后可能是家庭里边缺少安全感
当你总是盯着孩子的问题
却不去看看家庭的氛围的时候
就会陷入到这种恶性循环
那么这是我们的第四个思维
第五个思维
我是受害者
孩子让我很痛苦
有些父母呢
在教育当中常常会抱怨
孩子让我操碎了心
我的命怎么这么苦
那这种受害者的心态
就会让亲子关系陷入这种悲情的模式
就孩子感受到的不是爱
而是一种负担
所以教育从来不是谁拖累了我
而是一场双向的成长
你换个角度想
孩子的不完美
其实正是提醒我们
对吧该成长的不只是孩子
还有父母呢
如果说你正在亲子关系当中
感觉到无力
不妨先从舍弃这5个思路开始
当你放下了控制绑架和抱怨
才能够真正的看见孩子
也让孩子看见你啊
所以
亲子关系里边的这些错误的一些思维
其实有时候
我不知道大家有没有这种感觉
就是他会像一种无形的这么一个锁链
把父母和孩子都困住了
当我们舍弃了这些执念
哎很多时候关系他才有可能
怎么样才会真正的轻松起来
是不是
但其实我跟你们说
不只是亲子关系
就是你在生活里边的任何一段关系
都会受到思维的制约
尤其是在你的职场里边啊
就是我们同样会陷入一些想当然
的这么一个错误的认知
就让自己反复的受挫
是吧
那在工作里边对吧
当我们感觉到委屈或者不公的时候
如何跳出这种困境呢
所以那么接下来我们再来看一看
在职场对吧
受挫的时候
你要舍弃的5个
同样咱们也是5个思路
5个思路
谢谢大家啊
那还是那句老话
对吧觉得宋明老师讲的好的同学
大家记得加一下咱们的关注
对吧曼宁说咱们讲的好
来咱们把灯牌亮起来啊
把灯牌亮一亮
欢迎大家啊
如果错过了的同学
想看看我们直播回放的同学
我们也会加好字幕啊
把所有的直播的这些回放
都慢慢的
放到我们的这个会员专区里边啊
大家可以点击宋明老师的头像
然后点击会员专区
然后加入我们频道的会员
大家就可以看我们的这个直播回放了
好几天没播了
2天两三天
我们昨天开播的啊
昨天开播了好不好啊
哈哈非常需要
是吧嗯
那么在职场里边
我跟你们说
谁都可能遇到打击
对吧升职没轮到自己
项目失败
被领导否定
甚至同事背后使绊子啊
甚至是同啊
甚至同事背后使坏
那很多人就卡在这个困境里边出不来
其实不是因为环境多恶劣
而是因为自己的思维把自己给困住了
那么心理学家费斯廷格曾说过
他说生活里边10%是发生在你身上的
而90%是取决于你怎么看待它
那也就是说
职场挫折本身并不可怕
真正决定你能不能走出来的
是你的态度啊
是不是这样
啊
所以这位心理学家也是很厉害的
大家听过他的这个法则没有啊
hmm
对啊
所以说这个就是你的什么东西啊
大家打两个字叫做认知
认知啊
所以心理学家费斯汀格说过
生活里面10%是发生在你身上的事
90%都是取决于你怎么去看待它
啊而90%你担心的事
大概率是不会发生的
也就是说职场的挫折比啊
职场的挫折本身并不可怕
真正决定你能不能走出来的
是你的态度
那我也结合了很多学员
在职场当中的一些困扰
总结了5条
必须要舍弃的这么一个思维方式
啊那么第一个是什么呢
第一个就是一辈子稳定不变
大家打打字来
大家自己记一记啊
一辈子稳定不变
就我们说的什么铁饭碗
很多人对工作有一个幻想
只要进入到一家好公司对吧
我们就能安心干到退休
但现实是什么
时代会变
企业会变
行业会变
甚至老板和同事都会变
如果说你还执着于
只要进到这家公司就万事大吉
那我告诉你
一旦发生变故
你就会被打的措手不及
所以与其追求一辈子的安稳
不如培养自己随时能转行的能力
这是第一个
第二个思路
努力就一定有回报
有没有同学是这么想的
这是我们从小就被灌输的信念
我跟你说
但在职场里边并不总是成立
有时候你再怎么拼命的加班
也可能不被看见
有时候升职加薪未必靠的是最努力
而是靠的最会展示价值
大家打出来最会展示价值
不是说你有价值就可以
你要会学会去展示你的价值啊
所以与其抱怨不公平
不如调整你的思维
努力是必要的
但你要学会让努力被看见
让努力被看见啊
是不是啊
那么第三个思路
那领导必须赏识我
很多人都会陷在他应该他必须里边
对吧我这么卖力
那领导就应该该提拔我呀
我这么忠诚
那公司就该回馈我呀
但职场不是一个理想国
没有必须的
领导有他的这么一个选择权
对吧公司也有他的这么一个规则
你唯一能做的
就是让自己变得不可或缺
而不是等别人来满足你
心里边的这么一个应该
那么第四种呢
刚刚相反
都是我不够好当
项目失败对吧
晋升落空
那有的人第一反应就是
是不是我太笨了
不够优秀啊
所以这种自我否定只会让你陷得更深
职场挫折的原因有很多啊
我跟你们说环境
对吧机会人际
甚至是运气
自我检视固然重要
但别把所有的责任都背在自己的身上
失败不是你不行的证明
而是你还要需要找到更合适的方法
那么第五个受害者心态
为什么总是我倒霉
我怎么就遇上了这么一个同事
那你看
你一旦陷入到了受害者的心态
你的这个注意力
全部都放在了抱怨和不公平上了
但抱怨不能够改变结果
它只会让你更焦虑
所以真正的高手
他会把每一次的挫折
当做是升级的机会
今天的打击正好可能提醒你
哎是时候换个思维方
式
或者是迈向更高的这么一个平台了
那如果说你正在经历类似的职场困境
不知道该怎么走出来
也可以把情况告诉我
我会帮你理清思路
找到一个最适合你的
这么一个解决的方案
那么也欢迎大家来到
宋明讲心理的这么一个频道
那么我们一个频道是每一天对吧
早上7点 啊
给大家分享不同心理学的
这么一个一个直播间啊
如果说偶尔听一听
觉得对吧
对你有帮助的
不要忘了加咱们一个关注好不好啊
觉得有收获的同学
咱们打一个7字来
觉得有收获的
咱们打一个7字啊
记得加加咱们频道的关注
加加咱们频道的订阅啊
哼
hmm
也记得分享一下咱们的这个直播间啊
可以把它分享到你的朋友圈啊
大家点点分享啊
点点转发
点点转发啊
所以你看
职场的这个思维困境
其实在提醒我们
一个人的成长
不仅仅是外在的这么一个技能和努力
更是内心认知的一个冲突
或者是一个突破吧
所以你看
很多时候你之所以难以走出来
是因为你太习惯苛责自己了
你忘了给自己一点善意
对吧爱别人很容易
但要重新学会爱自己
却需要很大的勇气
是不是这样啊
嗯
老师当了解一个人的缺点的时候
心里就会被无限的放大
就想远离他
对每个人我都会这样
那很正常啊
因为人的脑子里边有一个东西
叫什么呢
叫做演绎
你会演绎这个东西
就是很多事没发生对吧
但是就是我们刚刚
说的费斯汀格法则啊
哼
所以爱别人很容易
但要重新学会爱自己
真的需要很大的这么一个勇气
那我们该如何做到去富养自己一次呢
对吧让心灵如何重新长出力量呢
那接下来就会带你从用爱对待自己
开始
走向一个新的成长啊
我不知道大家有没有见过这样的人
就是他对身边所有的人都充满了善意
愿意倾听朋友的抱怨
愿意为同事加班收费啊
愿意为同事加班
愿意为伴侣默默的付出
甚至路边一只流浪猫狗
他都会舍不得不管
可是很奇怪
他们就是不会善待自己
别人的一个请求
他就立刻答应啊
他们就会立刻答应
别人的一个请求
他们会立刻答应
自己哪怕身体已经疲惫到极点
他也不敢拒绝
这他们的爱心好像取之不尽
但就是不留一点给自己
为什么
为什么他们不爱自己啊
很多同学可能觉得这是一种善良
这是一种无私
但心理学告诉我们
不懂得爱自己的人
并不是没有能力
而是他背后有一种深深的心理逻辑
就是他们把不爱自己
当做一种和父母保持联系的方式
这句话能理解的
打个一字呢
把不爱自己
当做一种和父母保持联系的方式
有点深呐这句话
因为小时候
他们总是得不到父母的肯定嘛
取得好成绩
父母可能会说哎呀
下次还能更好
想要拥抱父母可说
父母可能会说哎呀
别粘别粘人
对吧做的再努力
也换不来一句真心的赞美
于是他们就学会了
一个潜意识的模式
如果我否定自己
委屈自己
哎我就能够和父母保持某种的连接
哪怕这种连接是痛苦的
那也是唯一熟悉的
那长大以后
他们还是在重复这个模式
于是我们看到了成年后的他们
在关系里边总是过度的付出
他不敢提出自己的需求
在职场上
总是挑最累的活
生怕别人说自己不够好
在生活里边也总是忽略自己
把所有的精力都给了别人
表面上你看他们是在爱别人
但实际上
他们都是在用不爱自己
去延续和父母之间的那份旧有的牵盼
但问题是
这种模式能带来幸福吗
大家觉得能带来幸福吗
当然不能
当一个人一直忽视自己
心里的这种匮乏感就会越来越重
就他们越努力的去爱别人
他越会感到孤独
他们越想被理解
越容易被忽视
因为世界其实在悄悄的回应你
如果连你自己都不爱自己
你又怎么期待别人来全心全意的爱你
啊
那么疗愈的开始是什么呢
那我告诉大家
就是你要学会再富养自己一次
富养不是说物质上的挥霍
而是心理上的滋养
当你累了
允许自己休息
而不是咬牙硬撑
当你难过的时候
允许自己哭泣
而不是假装坚强
当你想要的时候
勇敢的说出来
而不是一味的忍耐
这是你补偿给童年自己的一份礼物
因为那个时候的你没有被好好的爱过
那现在的你哎
有能力给自己这份爱
那
我也想说给正在看我们这一篇的同学
如果说你也曾
因为不够好
而努力去讨好过别人
如果你也常常感到自己不值得被爱
那我希望你记住
问题不在于你不够优秀
而是在于你太习惯忽略自己
所以从今天开始
试着把一点点的爱留给自己
就像你曾经对世界慷慨付出那样
把同样的温柔给自己这么一次
这不是自私
而是一种成长啊
因为当你真正的学会爱自己
那我告诉你
你的生命才会从内而外的疗愈
也才能给世界更健康的爱
那能听懂的同学
在评论区告诉我
你最想为自己富养的第一件事
会是什么呢
大家可以打在评论区里边啊
怎么跟我一样是吧啊
吃好睡好
学会放下
回家让自己来一场说走就走的旅行
圣母心往往喜欢妈宝男吗
我们上次说过这个话题啊
嗯
学会拒绝
放下杂念啊
敢于拒绝
心态归零
就是爱自己嗯
哈哈哈
大家说的都挺好的啊
活在当下对吧
接纳自己的不完美
不在乎别人的看法
做自己想做的嗯
想和松明老师一样被讨厌的勇气
孩子做错事
妈妈爱发脾气是什么情况
妈妈在孝敬权威呀
不接纳自己呀
老师生活中发脾气吗
也发脾气啊
啊我也有很多的创伤啊也会啊
嗯
我也是个人嘛哈哈哈
我跟大家说情绪稳定不是说不发脾气
情绪稳定我跟大家说过对吧
就是你和你的情绪是保持一致的啊
你如果不发脾气的话
你这个人
就会慢慢变成一个没有边界的人
大家理解吗
是不是这样
嗯啊
学会爱自己
我觉得是一种疗愈
真的
而学会面对外界的这种误解
或者是冤枉
那是一种修行
就是人生的路上
总会有时候被人怀疑
被人误解
对吧甚至你会蒙受这种不白之冤
可能你拼命的去解释过
却换来的更多的质疑
那你说怎么办啊
那有时候我跟你们说
沉默也是一种最有力的智慧啊
是吧啊
那么接下来
我们来讲一讲被冤枉时候的智慧啊
被冤枉的智慧
大家有被冤枉过吗
有的打一个一字来
在生活里边有被冤枉过
在职场啊
对吧在你的人际关系里边
有没有被冤枉的时候呀
往往你们会怎么做呀
啊被冤枉的时候你们会怎么做
可以跟我说说吗
很多次啊
常常有啊
有三四年的时间经历过这种痛苦啊
那我们今天来讲一讲好不好啊
断绝关系啊
沉默是金哈哈哈
看具体的事儿
得看具体的事
你有没有经历过这样的时刻
就是有人对你心生猜忌
明明你没做过的事
却偏偏被安在了你的头上
你可能急得满脸通红
拼命去解释
结果呢解释越多
别人越觉得你心虚
最后换来的可能不是曾经
而是一身的委屈
其实人生在世
对吧其实人生在世
被冤枉不被认同
几乎是每一个人都会面对的考验
在家庭里边
可能是父母误解你不够努力啊
在职场上
可能是领导怀疑你
偷偷的推卸责任
对吧在人际关系里边
可能是朋友听信流言
对你另眼相看
那这些时刻往往最令人心痛
你知道自
己是清白的
但却没有人愿意相信你
那么今天我们来聊一聊被冤枉的智慧
欢迎来到松明讲心理的频道
啊
那第一次来的同学记得点点关注啊
点点关注啊
把灯牌咱们亮一亮啊
小时候有一次被冤枉
到现在几十年都记得
是的
人对这种啊消极思维的记忆力特别好
特别好啊
谁给了你钱
你不一定记得住
对吧谁欠了你钱哎
这一辈子我都不会忘哼
是不是这样啊
我们常常会认为啊
只要讲清楚事实
就能够摆脱掉误解
但是在易经里边有这么一句话
他说啊同声相应
同气相求
就是一个人能不能相信你
并不取决于事实本身
而是取决于他的心
如果说他的心已经倾向于怀疑
那么你的解释只会被当成是掩饰
那如果说反过来
他的心愿意理解你
那么即便没有解释
他也会愿意等一等真相
所以当我们遭遇冤枉的时候
你要意识到
这不是真相有没有的问题
而是对方愿不愿意相信的问题
我这么说
能理解的打个一字来
大家想想
是不是这样啊
每个人都想告诉对方真相是什么
但是问题在于是什么
问题在于你对方愿不愿意信啊
他不就是不愿意信吗
哼
是不是是不是取决于别人啊
同学们
嗯
是这样的
对吧
你看
战国时期的屈原就是最典型的例子
忠心耿耿为楚国出谋划策
对吧却因为刚直不阿被小人嫉妒
对他对吧
被小人出卖
那楚怀王起初是信任他的呀
但是这种谣言越来越多他
也开始怀疑
但是屈原没有自证
他只能被流放
那面对这一切
他选择写下了离骚举世皆浊我独清
众人皆醉我独醒
大家听一听
这是多么孤独的一句话呀
屈原没有去逐一的辩驳那些小人
他明白那个毫无意义
他把忠诚和爱国寄托在了文字里边
留给后世
千年之后
我们记住的是屈原的清白与气节
却没有人再记得那些诋毁他的小人
这个就是易经明夷卦的智慧啊
明代表光明
夷代表受伤
当光明受到伤害的时候
不是去硬拼硬闯
而是要学会藏光养晦
保持沉默
把力量留给未来
把清白交给时间
那么在心理学里边也有一个现象
我们把它叫确认偏差
什么意思呢
就是一个人呐
一旦对你形成了
先入为主的这么一个判断
他就会下意识的寻找证据
来证明自己的想法
从而拿到一个价值感
你比方说有人怀疑你心里有鬼
哪怕你急着去解释
他都会说
你看他解释的这么快
肯定心虚
甚至说你的沉默呀
你的眼神
你的手势
都会被误解成此地无银三百两
这个叫做解释陷阱
你越想洗清自己
别人呢反而觉得你越可疑
那么心理学里边还有一个
我们把它叫做斯特里桑德效应
本来一件小事
没多少人注意
可一旦当事人急于澄清
反而让人觉得哎
你一定有事隐瞒
解释越多
怀疑越深
你看生活里边常常有这样的情况
一个孩子在学校里边
可能被误认为偷了同学的铅笔
或者别的东西
他会哭着喊着不是我对吧
那同学们会觉得他这么激动
有可能就是做贼心虚
结果孩子越解释
大家越不信
直到铅笔后来被找到
大家才发现误会他了
所以呢有时候让人信服的他
不是解释
而是事实
成年人也一样
在职场上对吧
如果说有人质疑你偷懒
你再怎么说我很努力哎
效果都有限
因为结果这个东西
才是最有力的证明
解释只会让别人觉得你在强调过程
而不是交出成绩
那么这种智慧
古人也早就懂了
在庄子啊
在庄子秋水里边
有这么一个故事啊
就是惠子被人诬陷
说他偷了邻居的一头啊
说他偷了邻居的一只大葫芦
那惠子呢
没有拼命的辩解
而是淡淡的一笑
说我虽贫
但不至于贪
区区一葫芦
别人一时半会可能不信
但随着时间的流逝
人们发现惠子依然清贫如旧
也依然坦荡做人
于是这个流言自然就消散了
那庄子就由此说他说辩者无用
明者自明
也就是说
真正清白的人
不需要用嘴巴去争辩
而是用一生的行为去证明
那你看这个和心理学的这个逻辑
其实是相通的呀
就是解释是满足不了别人的偏见
行动
才能真正的让时间成为你的见证人
所以当你被冤枉的时候
不妨记住这句话解释一时
未必能换来信任
沉默守心
终能赢得清白
你们还记不记得史记里边的李广啊
你看李广这个人
一生英勇善战
但是呢却屡次因为功劳被压制了
甚至被冤枉
结果失职了
那每一次
他都没有去大声的争辩
而是默默的承受
虽然生前郁郁不得志
但后世称他为飞将军
传颂的是他的忠勇和清廉
而不是那些误解
你看现在的社会里边
我们也常常也能看到类似的一些场景
对吧一个职场人被同事暗中中伤
说他偷懒不干活呀
他没有和同事撕破脸
而是选择用更加实际的行动去证明
比别人更认真
更努力更有担当
那一段时间以后
对吧领导和同事自然就看到了差别
那个中伤他的人
反而失去了信用
所以你看
冤枉永远都只是暂时的阴影
而时间永远都站在了真相这边
易经里边说什么呢
他说君子以厚德载物
真正的君子
面对误解
他不会急于争辩
而是以德行去承载
用时间来澄清
因为谣言止于智者
小人或许能够一时得逞
但最终会被真相和人心所淘汰
我们要做的
就是守住自己的心
不被流言扰乱
继续修炼自己
继续积累实力
就像那句古话不怕千万人阻挡
只是怕自己投降
这冤枉并不可怕
可怕的是你因为别人的质疑
而丢掉了自己的方向
那从国学的角度来讲
被冤枉其实也是人生修行的一部分
大家有没有听过否极泰来
否代表闭塞
泰代表通达
那一个人被冤枉
就是处在一个痞阶段
对吧所有的路都会被堵上
但如果说你能沉得住气
不急于辩解
反而能在这段时间你能够积蓄能量啊
那我告诉你
等时机一到
你自会走向泰的这么一个境界
心理学其
实也有类似的说法的
他说人在被误解的时候
最容易产生这种无力感和这种愤怒感
但如果说
你学会把这种情绪转化成为动力
那你就会变得更加的坚韧
更加的笃定
那这
就是冤枉带给我们的一个反向的礼物
对吗所以
看不见的心理
看得见的心理学
当你下次再被冤枉
不要慌也不要拼命的去解释
先稳住自己的心
告诉自己清者自清
浊者自浊
与其浪费时间在无谓的争辩里边
不如用行动
不如用行动去证明自己
这个世界也许一时看不见你
但时间会站在你这边
你要相信
真正有价值的人
最终都不需要靠辩解来证明
正如论语里边说的
君子欲讷于言而敏于行
所以沉默是一种深沉的力量
那我想问问你
你有没有经历过被冤枉
被误解的时刻呀
那时候的你是拼命的在去解释
还是选择了沉默呀
大家可以在评论区告诉我
我们一起来聊一聊这份人生的智慧